hi everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my video for the extended cut of
Avengers endgame that's right there Reed
releasing Avengers endgame in theaters
even though it's still technically in
theaters right now with a new
post-credit scene in a whole bunch of
extra footage after the credits so I'll
explain what that is and talk about
Marvel's comic-con panel because Kevin
Feige said that they are coming back and
they will be showing off some stuff in
Hall H we're doing that spider-man far
from home imax ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Spider Man or Avengers
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so the big
news is is they've been doing the press
junkets for spider-man far from home
while the press was asking Kevin Feige a
whole bunch of different questions
there's like four or five different
videos based on the big teasers that he
dropped during his interviews one of
them was just him casually mentioning oh
yeah next weekend we're gonna re-release
Avengers endgame in theaters with a
bunch of extra footage after the credits
he said that it's actually not
technically an extended cut of the film
so it's the theatrical cut with a whole
bunch of stuff tacked on at the end as
sort of a new post-credit scene alright
we know how long that is so we know how
much extra footage there's going to be
but this is his exact quote he says not
an extended cut but there will be a
version going into theaters with a bit
of a marketing push with a few new
things at the end of the movie if you
stay and watch the movie after the
credits there will be a deleted scene a
little tribute in a few surprises which
will be next weekend that means a week
from me posting this video so not this
weekend but the following weekend
depending on when you're watching this
video sometimes people don't see my
videos to like a week after I post them
so we're talking June 28th is when the
new cut of Avengers endgame is supposed
to hit theaters there hasn't been a lot
of news about which theaters are going
to be screening this special cut and if
they're gonna be doing it
internationally but tickets go on sale
June 24th that's next Monday and they
didn't say how long the extended cut is
going to be in theaters if it'll just be
that one weekend or if it'll be an
entire week I think that whatever they
do it will stop screening
before spider-man far from home hits
theaters so that they don't cannibalize
its opening weekend box office too much
but the whole reason for them doing this
is so that they can beat avatars
worldwide box office record they're
within about 40 million dollars maybe a
little bit less than that now so they
don't need that much so obviously Kevin
Feige is dangling the carrot we see what
you're doing they're putting a whole
bunch of extra post-credit scenes on
Avengers end games so that will by
double tickets that's the funny thing
too you're basically buying a ticket to
go see an extra post-credit scene who's
gonna do that and everybody just raises
their hand of course I've seen Avengers
endgame a couple times of course I'm
gonna buy a ticket for just a couple
minutes of extra footage the extended
cut is gonna be about seven minutes
longer than the regular cut so you will
have to buy a special ticket it's not
the regular screening so just make sure
when you try to buy a ticket on Monday
that is for the quote-unquote special
cut of Avengers endgame or whatever they
call it because Kevin Feige said that
they're gonna have a special marketing
push they'll let you know what it's
gonna be called so they'll have special
listing so you'll know how to
differentiate it from the regular cut of
Avengers endgame we already know what
all the blu-ray bonus features are going
to be for Avengers endgame so I'm
guessing that some of the blu-ray bonus
features will be part of this special
extra footage but the deleted scene that
he's talking about that they tacked on
odds are pretty good that it's gonna be
the scene of Katherine Langford playing
the adult version of Iron Man's daughter
Morgan's start talking to him in that
orange space of the soul world inside
the soul gem right after he snaps Thanos
and his army away with his improvised
Infinity Gauntlet because they shot it
completely they finished the scene in
editing and even showed it to test
audiences and had to remove it at the
last minute because people just did not
get who she was they didn't realize that
she was supposed to be his adult
daughter the whole reason for the scene
being in the movie is that it was meant
to be a mirror for Thanos is seen with
younger more after he snaps everyone and
she says did you do it what did it cost
and he says everything in the intention
in that Thanos version of the scene
during Avengers infinity war is that
he's talking to a piece of Gamora soul
the Gamora that he sacrificed who still
doesn't come back because the Gamora at
the end of Avengers endgame is actually
the Gamora from 2014 that got pulled out
of time still a couple Gamora questions
going into guardians of the galaxy vol 3
as guardians of the galaxy the Iron Man
version of
the scene was meant to be a little more
positive and make him feel better about
what he'd done sacrificing his life
knowing that he was gonna die when he
snapped Thanos away just because he's a
normal human so no matter how much
technology he was using the force of the
gauntlet was just going to overwhelm his
body I don't know what the dialogue was
but it was kind of a version of the
scene that he had with Pepper Potts
right before he passes away where she
says you did it we're gonna be okay
you can rest now you can still hear
spider-man crying his way to spider-man
far from home in the background of this
scene everywhere I go I see his face I
[Music]
miss him too
there are a whole bunch of other deleted
scenes that I've already done videos
about I'll link those at the end of this
it could be another deleted scene
because remember it's only seven minutes
long so there's a couple different
things they're gonna be happening during
that so whatever the deleted scene is
it's probably only a couple minutes this
Iron Man spider-man scene is just an
example of one of the deleted scenes
that they've released already this
historic
the tribute the Kevin Feige is talking
about is the Stan Lee tribute from the
blu-ray bonus features but it's a
cut-down version of it because the Stan
Lee tribute on the blu-ray is gonna be
way way longer for the extra last few
minutes the quote unquote something
special the Kevin Feige mentions might
be part of the gag reel or even a peek
at some of the Marvel phase 4 movie
concept art or something in that vein I
don't think that it's gonna be anything
spider-man far from home related but
remember is basically seven extra
minutes after avengers endgame credits
so just brand-new post credit scene
whatever ends up happening I'll do a
video for it of course I'm in go see it
in theaters so don't worry there'll be a
new Easter egg video as soon as they
drop that when we get to Comic Con in
about a week before that comes out I'll
actually do giveaways for the blu-ray
itself so no worries but speaking of
Marvel's Comic Con so big news is
Marvel's returning to Hall H because
they skipped last year because it was
before Avengers endgames marketing push
began it was right after they dusted all
the heroes so they're like we're not
quite ready to talk about everybody
coming back just a couple months right
after we killed most of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they've been putting
up banners around the Gaslamp Quarter
near the San Diego Convention Center
they all say we love you 3,000 from the
Avengers Kevin Feige did say that they
would be showing off some special stuff
but the only movie that they'll have
actually been shooting when comic-con
stars is the Black Widow movie they're
shooting that right now comic-con is at
the end of July they will have not
started shooting the Eternals movie or
Schanke yet they could show off a black
widow clip but they wouldn't have time
to finish special effect so it'd be
pretty bra they will probably announce
the Marvel phase 4 schedule or at least
the first half of it through 2022
maybe let us know when the next Avengers
movie is going to be and just call it
the untitled Avengers movie like they
did for Avengers in game for a couple
years maybe a concept reel for some of
those movies they do concept art years
and years before movies comes out they
use that in their pitches when they're
trying to figure out what a movie is
actually going to look like when they
start to cast it right now the Marvel
phase 4 movie schedule that we know
about our Black Widow in Eternals movies
next year they start shooting at Turtles
really
20:21 will be blacc panther2 Doctor
Strange - maybe shang-chi - depending on
when they start shooting that movie 2022
is gonna be guardians of the galaxy 3
maybe as guardians of the galaxy with
Thor as implied by the ending of
Avengers endgame should fight one
another for the honor of leadership me
yes
maybe Captain Marvel 2 and then a third
movie we don't know what that third
movie is going to be but Kevin Feige has
said that they're looking at doing an
OVA movie Thor for ant-man in the wasp 3
and then obviously Avengers 5 and it
should go without saying that of course
they're gonna do spider-man 3 but
technically spider-man 3 doesn't count
against Marvel's phase 3 movies when
they say they're doing 3 movies per year
because Sony releases the Spider Man
solo films not Disney and Marvel even
though Spider Man is in the MCU those
solo films are in the MCU it's still
Sony's name on everything they're the
ones that market it they spend all the
money to make the trailers and put it in
theaters so spider-man 3 is probably
gonna happen sometime in 2021 I guess
they could wait three years but usually
those spider-man films are out every two
years and Sony loves them that
spider-man money so I just don't see
them waiting three years for that next
spider-man film what's happening next
year though because there was originally
gonna be three movies they took
guardians of the galaxy three off the
schedule Sony's venom Morbius spin-off
movie with Jared Leto took that spot so
that's gonna be a summer movie next year
so they'll still be the same number of
comic book movies next year but one of
them will be a Sony venom verse movie
instead of being guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 Kevin Feige also did confirmed
that Sony was planning on doing a venom
crossover with Tom Hollands spider-man
but I'll do a separate video about that
but it did confirm based on the way he
explained it that they will be
continuing to make spider-man 3 with
Sony so if you were worried that they
weren't gonna resign the sharing
arrangement for Tom Hollands spider-man
character do not worry anymore but Kevin
Feige did say that they would talk more
about the future of spider-man in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe after
spider-man far from home hit theaters
that presentation might also be
part of their Hall H panel there's all
those Avengers TV shows they're doing on
the Disney Plus streaming service they
could use part of the Hall H panel to
talk about that maybe show off some
concept teasers I'm not expecting a lot
of really big x-men or Fantastic Four
teasers or news but Kevin Feige did say
that they had already started planning
for what they were gonna do with those
characters they've been having pitch
meetings about different characters
different concepts for where they would
fit those people in the MCU movies
during Marvel phase four and Marvel
phase five for the most part that's a
little further off so don't expect any
Marvel x-men or fantastic for movies or
big characters until after 2022 I'll be
doing a bunch of spider-man far from
home videos in the next couple of weeks
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those
videos the other really cool thing you
probably heard about is live-action
spider-verse being teased by Sony
they really are thinking about putting
Tobey Maguire's spider-man Tom Hollands
spider-man in Andrew Garfield spider-man
in a movie together sometime in the
future but no timeline for when that
would happen I will probably do a
separate video about that to explain how
it would work in what they said exactly
about it my next big video will probably
be about the spider-man venom crossover
so look out for that congratulations to
the giveaway winner for my last big
Marvel video marcus mm please email me
on the about page my channel so I can
get your details click here for my
non-spoilery early spider-man far from
home review and click here for a whole
bunch of Avengers endgame deleted scenes
in the alternate ending of the movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]